in this video we take a look at setting
up the custom loss function for training
in the default loss function all samples
such as these code snippets are treated
the same irrespective of their content
but there are scenarios where it could
make sense to weight the samples
differently if for example one sample
contains a lot of tokens that are of
interest to us or if a sample has a
favorable diversity of tokens
we can also implement other heuristics
with pattern matching or other rules
for each sample we get a lost value
during training and we can combine that
loss with a weight
then we can create a weighted sum or
average over all samples to get the
final loss for the batch
let's have a look at a specific example
we want to set up a language model that
helps us auto complete common data
science code
for that task we could
we would like to wait samples stronger
where tokens related to the data science
stack such as pd or np occur more
frequently
here you see a loss function that does
exactly that for causal language
modeling
it takes the model's input and predicted
logits as well as the key tokens as
input
first the inputs and logics are aligned
then the loss per sample is calculated
followed by the weight
finally the loss and the weight are
combined and returned
this is a pretty big function so let's
take a closer look at the loss and the
weight blocks
during the calculation of the standard
loss the logits and labels are flattened
over the batch
with the review we unflatten the tensor
to get the matrix with a row for each
sample in the batch and a column for
each position in the sequence of the
sample
we don't need the loss per position so
we average the loss over all positions
for each sample
for the weights we use boolean logic to
get a tensor with once where a keyword
occurred and zeros were not
this tensor has an additional dimension
as the loss tensor we just saw because
we get the information for each keyword
in a separate matrix
we only want to know how many times
keywords occurred per sample so we can
sum over all keywords and all positions
per sample
now we're almost there we only need to
combine the loss and with the weight per
sample
we do this with element wise
multiplication and then average over all
samples in a batch
in the end we have exactly one loss
value for the whole batch
and this is the whole necessary logic to
create a custom weighted loss
let's see how we can make use of that
custom loss with accelerate and the
trainer
in accelerate we just pass the input ids
to the mod to get the logits and then we
can call the custom loss function
after that we continue with the normal
training loop by for example calling
backward
for the trainer we can overwrite the
compute loss function of the standard
trainer
we just need to make sure that we return
the loss and the model outputs in the
same format
with that you can integrate your own
awesome loss function with both the
trainer and accelerate
you